well I think everyone's human so
obviously they're they're prone
initially to certain gut reactions
they're probably not very strategic and
how they handle that that scandalous
information or that controversy and they
really need a third party advising them
who's studied a lot of different cases
and incidents of scandals and we start
we're starting to see kind of
generalizable strategies first get all
the information out there and be
truthful and you know there's a whole
growing field of of crisis communication
now and I think it's it's like anything
else that you really probably need to
prepare for crisis and you need to have
a plan in place that you can adapt to
the situation when a crisis or scandal
does occur and if you're not prepared
you're gonna make a lot of mistakes